et d'abord à madame la Présidente Pascal
grunis pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
même la première ministre depuis une
semaine la mobilisation sociale contre
la réforme des retraites paralyse notre
pays provoquant une nouvelle fois les
aspiration de nos compatriotes
dépendants des transports publics comme
d'habitude ce sont les Français les plus
fragiles qui sont pénalisés ceux qui ne
peuvent pas se permettre de prendre des
jours de congés ni télétravailler et qui
n'ont d'autre solution de transport que
le train le bus ou le métro il n'est pas
acceptable qu'une minorité de Français
prennent ainsi en otage les salariés qui
veulent travailler mais aussi nos
artisans et commerçants déjà lourdement
impactés par les cris sanitaires
énergétiques si le droit de grève est
garanti par la Constitution il n'est pas
pour autant un droit de blocage de tout
autre de tout un pays bien que la loi de
2007 est organisée l'information des
usagers en cas de grève elle n'a
cependant pas permis d'aboutir un
service minimum garanti
c'est ce qui a conduit le Sénat à
adopter le 4 février 2020 une
proposition de loi de notre collègue
président Bruno Retailleau permettant
enfin de limiter le droit de grève si
cela s'avère nécessaire pour garantir un
service minimal madame la Première
ministre ne croyez-vous pas qu'il est
grand temps de reprendre ce texte à
votre compte et de le faire adopter dans
les meilleurs délais
merci chers
c'est qui qui répond
ent merci mes chers collègues d'écouter
les questions parce que s'il y a du
charivaris ça peut être aussi envers
vous tout à l'heure donc restons calme
allez pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur Clément bonne ministre délégué
chargé des transports
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
Présidente Grigny comme vous je veux
penser aux nombreux Françaises et
Français qui ces derniers jours et à de
nombreuses occasions vivent
malheureusement douloureusement les
perturbations dans nos transports
publics et sont empêchés parfois de
retrouver leur famille de les travailler
et dans un certain nombre de activités
essentielles et nous devons je crois
agir avec à chaque fois deux
orientations extrêmement claires d'abord
le respect évidemment de nos grands
principes notamment le droit de grève
qui vous le savez est inscrit et garanti
par notre Constitution et puis bien sûr
de la manière la plus concrète et
pratique possible l'intérêt des usagers
pourquoi je crois quand la matière il
est essentiel de ne pas se nourrir de
slogan mais d'avoir des réponses
extrêmement efficaces précises et
concrètes la question d'asservice
minimum fait partie de ces réflexions
anciennes la réalité c'est que si on le
définissait en termes de pourcentage de
services je crois que on ne répondrait
pas à la problématique que vous évoquez
pourquoi parce que si on définissait un
seuil extrêmement propos de services
cela serait jugé sans doute
inconstitutionnel puisque cela serait
une atteinte disproportionnée au droit
de grève garanti par notre plafonda
mental et si on définissait un
pourcentage de services trop bas on
serait pas efficace parce que même quand
il y a des mobilisations très
importantes nous l'avons vu par exemple
à Noël avec les contrôleurs de la SNCF
heureusement d'ailleurs plus de 50 % du
service reste assuré mais en fin de
nombreux Français sont pénalisés et donc
je crois d'ailleurs dans l'esprit de la
loi de 2007 qu'il faut que nous
cherchions et c'est la réflexion que
nous avons engagé sous l'autorité de la
première ministre à regarder les
réponses concrètes efficaces
complémentaires à certains nombres
d'ailleurs sont entre les mains de nos
entreprises publiques et nous avons
d'ores et déjà demandé aux dirigeants
des grandes entreprises publiques de
veiller par exemple à ce que il puisse y
avoir une mobilisation interne qui soit
renforcée cela nécessite de
l'organisation et de l'anticipation
puisque il faut parfois les
habilitations de sécurité pour exercer
certaines fonctions dans nos transports
publics ça c'est une réponse que nous
devons et que nous pouvons renforcer
dans les semaines et dans les mois qui
viennent nous pouvons là encore
d'ailleurs dans l'esprit de la loi 2007
réfléchir à la question des délais de
prévenance qui sont aujourd'hui ça a été
instauré dans la loi de 2007 de 48
heures qui pourraient être débattue et
nous pourrions travailler collectivement
à réfléchir à leur extension et puis
j'entends aussi parfois dans le débat
beaucoup de choses qui sont votre temps
est écoulé merci
la parole est maintenant Madame Nathalie
Goulet pour le groupe Union centriste ah
pardon pardon pardon
pardon non non vous applaudirez tout à
l'heure je ne voulais pas voler les 34
secondes de madame la Présidente GRUY
monsieur le ministre moi j'entends bien
mais depuis 2020 on aurait pu travailler
sur sur ce sujet ensemble moi j'ai été
le rapporteur de ce texte nous avons
fait des propositions tout ce que je
vous dis en fait on a bien sûr une
solution derrière franchement vous
demande quelque chose de faire parce que
on en a besoin on en a besoin pour
l'économie de la France on peut pas
pénaliser aujourd'hui tous les
travailleurs il y a des gens dans la rue
ok mais tous ceux qui restent chez eux
qui peuvent pas faire grève peut-être et
surtout qui ont besoin de travailler
c'est à eux qu'il faut penser c'est
toujours notre intérêt merci merci
la parole